nace la super liga europea de fútbol una
competición creada y gobernada por 12 de
los clubes más importantes de toda
europa a los que esperan que se unan
otros tres miembros fundadores de cara
al futuro los clubes fundadores esperan
mantener conversaciones con la uefa y la
fifa buscando las mejores soluciones
para la superliga y para el conjunto del
fútbol mundial
florentino pérez presidente del real
madrid será el primer líder de esta
nueva liga que rivalizará con la actual
champions league principal y más
importante competición de clubes
europeos los clubes fundadores alegan
motivos económicos para la creación de
esta liga que según ellos ayudarán al
fútbol en general la pandemia ha
desvelado que una visión estratégica y
un enfoque comercial son necesarias para
aumentar el valor y las ayudas en
beneficio de la pirámide del fútbol en
su conjunto la competición estará
compuesta por 20 equipos los 15
fundadores más 5 que serán invitados
anualmente en función de su rendimiento
en la temporada anterior en la primera
fase habrá dos grupos de diez los tres
mejores de cada grupo se clasificarán
para cuartos de final y los cuartos y
quintos de cada grupo
en un playoff adicional a partir de ese
momento se jugarán rondas
clasificatorias a doble partido que
acabarán con una final en campo neutral
la fifa mostró su desaprobación a una
nueva competición a la que calificó de
liga cerrada y extendida si bien se
mostró abierta al diálogo
la fifa siembre defiende la unidad en el
mundo del fútbol y pide a las partes
involucradas en esta discusión acalorada
a que participa en un diálogo calmado
constructivo y balanceado por el bien
del juego y en el espíritu de la
solidaridad en el juego limpio la
competición comenzará el próximo agosto
y deberá ver a su primer campeón en mayo